For humans, finding love can be a struggle,
with all the swiping and liking and texting.
But our world of modern romance is pretty
peaceful compared to the trauma that can come
with leopard slug love.
Because, you see, this slug had his penis
chewed off, but it’s not as crazy as you
might think.
Let me take you through the entire encounter
so you can understand why this slug’s last
sexual experience was cut short.
First, you should know that terrestrial slugs
are hermaphrodites, so they are capable of
fertilizing themselves, but they also have
the option to mate with a partner.
When the time is right, they release pheromones
into their slime to let other slugs know their
ready for action.
So when these two slugs spotted each other,
it was clear they were both in the mood.
So they begin to engage in a splendid rendition
of the pre-copulatory ebbs and flows of movement
and gyration that leopard slugs are well known
for.
They lick and nibble one another as they danced
around a very slimy circle.
For slugs, foreplay is a big part of the courting
process and it can last for hours.
After the blissfully slow rhumba, they find
a nearby tree and climb it together.
Slug penises are unusually large - nearly
the size of their bodies - so they need help
from gravity during copulation.
As the pair hang from a string of mucus like
acrobats, they start to pump fluids into their
alien esc penises and coil them together in
a knot-like fashion.
Wait, did I mention that leopard slug penises
come out of their heads?
It’s called a gonopore, and it’s the genital
opening of many invertebrates.
Anyways, the slug lovers continue their upside-down
version of the horizontal bop for another
several hours… and then the sperm exchange
begins.
This is where things can go wrong.
Leopard slug penises have corkscrew-like shape,
which result in intricate tangling during
sex.
While sometimes slugs are able to free their
phalluses, in this case, one slug got impatient
and simply bit its partner’s penis off.
This process is called APOphallation - and
it means that the new sex life of the bitten
partner is a little different.
This slug used to be euphallic – with a
fully functional penis; but now it’s hemiphallic
– which means that its penis is still there
in a really truncated form but it doesn’t
actually work.
But, like I said before, this isn’t all
that uncommon and this slug will be able to
mate again, just as a female.
No sperm, no problem for this formerly hung
slug.
So, there you have it, humans.
The next time you get ghosted after a date
just be thankful that at least your genitals
are still intact.
If you want to see more copulation creations,
check out this Wild Sex playlist!
Let us know in the comments what animal sex
stories you want to see.
If you want more stories right now, grab a
copy of the book Wild Sex, written by me,
Dr. Carin Bondar.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe!